welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
cannabis is personal learn how your
genetics play a big role
presented by Len mae CEO and Ocana
health
my name is Xavier courtiers and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Lynn Mei I will now
turn the presentation over to him well
thank you Xavier and welcome everyone I
really appreciate the opportunity this
is you know my passion I love to talk
about the end of cannabinoid system and
I'd love to talk about the personal
experience that people have with
calories so just to kind of give you a
little bit of thought background
overview I figure already gave an
introduction but I am the co co-founder
and O Canada health I have some
certifications like long board member of
the California cannabis Association and
it was a past president of the cannabis
Action Network but my passion has always
been that therapeutic properties of the
cement plant so in starting my
presentation I always like to kind of
give you the audience a background into
on what my best top looks like so this
is it really really I just captured a
screenshot of what my desktop looks like
and as you guys can see there are a lot
of tabs open and the reason why I do
this is to give everybody an overview of
sort of a glimpse into what happens in
my my brain so I was diagnosed with
attention deficit disorder when I was
saying when I was a kid and in my teens
I was putting all kinds of prescription
medication but the kind of Av being that
I have is sort of theta D that looks
like my best lot there's a lot of
different tabs that constantly open up
in my brain and it's very very difficult
for me to focus on one single thing so
as a kid growing up I would have all
these thoughts and there would be sort
of like the tabs there don't open my
computer and once I was put on
prescription medication you know some
good work all that made me feel awful
and I was lucky enough that I was able
to find cannabis and there was a it was
an experience in my in my late teens
that I had where that experience really
led to me discovering that this is a
medicine that works for me so when I
first
accidentally consume cannabis without
known what it was the world sort of
slowed down I saw all these times still
kind of were going through but I could
actually sit down and focus so that way
it allowed me to be able to sydney class
pay attention and focus on certain tasks
so this became my go-to medicine and i
was able to get off all the prescription
medication that it was on and my parents
really happy with that experience and
they asked me to leave so I did and
started pursuing trying to figure out a
way how I can make a difference how can
I make a difference and have other
people really recognize that this this
plan works for them as well hasn't it
for me so I was little I was at a music
event and I spotted some people that
were registering people to vote and they
said cannabis actually they had a little
bag er walked up to them and said nobody
guys don't want us at register and
people vote we're trying to make a
difference in the cannabis industry and
so long story short I became the
president of the cannabis action at work
and I held a rally at Independence Hall
in Philadelphia wish under originally
from Philadelphia and this is on federal
property where the the collision and
this is the Constitution all written in
head paper by plate and I had a keynote
speaker 90 note speaker this lady named
Pell be the secant and L DS one of the
first people to get federally prescribe
cannabis under the knighted program and
she was able to consume cannabis in
front of federal Rangers the whole
property with her can a metal kind of
jar of pre-rolled medical or medicinal
cannabis joints and she was able like
that but like adopted from those Rangers
and it was legal and this is going back
to 1993 some slaving aging myself but
the experience I had from a legal
standpoint this shed a light on what the
future will look like but I thought it
was gonna be something that's gonna
happen quickly but it took you know over
20 years but I had to happen in
Pennsylvania for instance but the
experience that I really want to talk
about is what happened next day so
everybody from the rally the state of my
house and we got woken up to a very loud
noise and
I'll be happy to walk into a sculpture I
had in my house broken and the reason
why she did that is because she couldn't
see it so LD who is getting at this on
cannabis for upper spine under the
federal program for heard the cheddar
bukhoma so she was legally blind but I
witness an incredible act that occurred
and there was my aha moment my eye
witness I'll be Medicaid with cannabis
I sure was able to see now granted she
still wore glasses and you know they're
plenty thick but she was able to see so
that was my second moment when I came to
the realization the cannabis didn't just
work for me personally but also work for
other people so this has to be a
therapeutic product that can make a
difference in many people's lives so
ibogaine began like journey by pursuing
any means in ways that I can get
cannabis and actually suggest that and
provide that to people that have all
kinds of different conditions and you
know my journey led me to into
California to the Los Angeles area I
involved in the dispensary space for a
while and then involved in entomology
cultivation and and and I was trying to
figure out a way on how to deliver this
product to so many different people and
I started getting some interesting
feedback so we would find a strain or
you know we like to call more about king
of our cultivar because trade does refer
has a reference to a virus but in
qinghua which is a profile of cannabis
and we would recommend or suggest to
provide that and facilitate that to a
person that had a specific condition
let's say Parkinson's for an example and
we find that profile that work for that
person and if we send them to a
dispensary and say okay you know now go
and get this
maybe it was blue a dream just as an
example and sometimes they would call me
up and say well it's not working for me
I could not understand why why wasn't it
working for them what I know they
weren't there so there was soem possible
reasons number one the the cultivator
may have not known exactly what the
product was the dispensary may have
mislabeled or there could have been some
other kind of business we weren't sure
so I began sort of uh somebody has atb
can't focus or he can hyper focus so
when something really stimulates you in
certain way we have a mounted opiate
released you hyper focus on this so I
became obsessed my obsession was to try
to find the answer to this so I came
across a video by a gentleman named
Kevin Kernan who first genetically
sequenced catalyst and reached out to
Kevin and began a relationship with
Kevin company called medicinal genomics
where I was able to go around the
country and extract DNA from different
plants from different cannabis plants
purify that DNA and I send it over to a
sequencer in Boston or we can start
getting a cannabinoid library so they
start understanding the different
effects of of the different cannabinoids
these herpes are in the plant and
understand what the makeup of them are
the second part of that was and there
was own a company that they their parent
company was called quartzion life
sciences where they did human genetic
sequencing and in doing that I started
looking at ways how do human genetic
markers interact with or in the
cannabinoid system and that sort of
began my journey in trying to figure out
why cannabis is personal so before I go
into that I want to go into the
endocannabinoids system a little bit and
really explain how the system works
based on my understanding of the system
so the anatomy system is our primary
regulatory system within
I not only this regulate you know on a
new digestive system I reckon it's bone
growth regulates organs reproductive
organs etc but we have these we have
these acknowledgments and the
cannabinoids that actually our body
produces so we all have cannabis inside
of us in some way or another so in
addition to creating these these
endogenous and the cannabinoids that are
really called ligands in a way they are
there are also receptors that were born
with there are receptors within our body
they're activated by these ligands as
well and there's also enzymes that
control the way that those linings are
expressed now doing today little more
detail but I'd like to give an example
of how that would work so what happens
is when we have when our body is in
homeostasis which is the way that and
only functions we have the amount of big
dodgers and cannabinoids that are being
produced at the passive level that is
great for us as individual however when
we begin to have a deficiency they are
not actually producing and their
cannabinoids the endogenous ones there
are body reacts there certain way so
let's say that we have a let's say that
we have a deficiency in one over in
Dodgers when the cannabinoids Islanders
tree that I really want to focus on one
of them is called Ananda mite the other
one is called - a gene and they're also
ligands they activate those receptors
and bind to those receptors so if there
is a deficiency in our endogenous and
the cannabinoids our body responds to
that so it can respond to that in
several different ways number one and
giving a stress response so depending on
what type of enzyme deficiency you have
in your body there's two different
pathway pathways on your
cb1 and cb2 receptors and think about
cb1 receptors bath toys that have an
association with an and might Ananda
mice also referred to as a bliss hormone
and I has a lot to do with the way their
body responds to stress so anxiety
depression all these different things
and the two AG that is more associated
with the cb2 receptor pathway and that
has a lot to do with a meal response so
just to give you sort of an example of
how that work let's say that you have a
deficiency in the way that your natural
Ananda - producer you pass the levels
are low and there is a stressful event
or somebody cuts you off in traffic
there's some illness something happens
in in the moment we have a stressful
event and if that happens your body
responds to that and because you have a
deficiency there there's also cortisol
that's releases here bud stream the
cortisol exacerbates a feeling anxiety
or stress or you know even you may be
paranoia of some source but there is a
response
now you ii receptor areas the CBT
research area which is associated with
your immune system as well that can also
produce a response in addition to the
stress response which is more mentally
the physical response is your immune
response so you may have an over ITAT
stimulation of your immune system which
can attack that area and create
inflammation that inflammation can send
the signal of pain discomfort back to
through your on to receptor site to your
central nervous system so you have new
transmitters and that information those
appear your transmitter and that
produces a feeling of pain or discomfort
where you by research as that pain
discomfort and addressed an overactive
immune response so you're you're under
cannabinoid system is out of whack
so what and there's a
things that happen and I'll go into a
little bit deeper on the enzyme or the
the cellular level as well but what
happens is we have a deficiency so
that's the case we were lucky enough
that we found one single plant so far in
nature the possesses cannabinoids and
turkeys which on it will also go into
the mimic the way our own endogenous and
the cannabinews work so to find the
right ratio for an individual to be able
to mimic and activate those receptors
they're already in our bodies that can
fill those gaps that we have naturally
and allow us to really regain
homeostasis which is balanced so what
happens is that inflammation begins to
to reduce once that information begins
to reduce that signal of pain or
discomfort goes away and a subsides and
then you have regained homeostasis again
so how does that happen and what happens
to our bodies well what happens in our
body see how that really works is a
matter of different cabinets and I want
to talk about a few specific ones that
everybody probably knows but the two
most common ones are THC and CBD so just
a preface the way what would you get the
cannabinoids that are in their natural
raw state and you get them from the
plant and you consume them the
psychotropic effect where the conversion
doesn't happen until you heat that
molecule when you heat that molecule the
THC and see the return or platform they
have an acid molecule it's attached when
you heed that the process called
decarboxylation the acid molecule is
released and there's a conversion as an
in-form of THC to Delta nine
tetrahydrocannabinol which does give you
that sacred giant psychotropic effect so
the two most common cannabinoids are THC
and CBD as I mentioned before now I want
to touch on CBD for emitting because CB
is kind of the dial and what happens is
since it's very prevalent in the market
and my my talk isn't about you know the
galleys per se but because it because
the farm bill it's becoming even more
prominent easy accessible I mean some
amazing amazing cannabinoid it has a lot
of true legacy therapeutic benefits and
antibacterial protective and new
protective is extremely important
especially for athletes and our veterans
and people that have brain injuries
anti-inflammation which is huge and as i
mentioned before on the CB two pathways
reduction of information there's disease
states like cancer for instance that
have information it's associated with
that and it's it works really well to
address some the other side inflammatory
conditions suppressing muscle spasms all
that is amazing and credit however i
absolutely want to point out a couple of
things about CBD now CBD and
cannabinoids in general are moderators
so what i mean by that is there is a
post synaptic and presynaptic modulation
that occurs and cannabinoids but really
interesting because they get signals
from our bodies those signals then go
back to a post synaptic response in the
form of thought the ananda might or to
EG which is a cannabinoid it's really
similar to how THC can actually
exacerbate or work without without
receptor site or on that loggin as you
say but what happens is that information
this comes back postsynaptically and
then those upstream to communicate to
our bodies in a central nervous system
what needs to happen how regulate what
we need more or less of so what happens
in the form of CBD is IC
may I as an uptake inhibitor because of
its modulating on effect so what I mean
by that is and where I want to point out
just kind of an area to be aware of when
somebody's consuming a prescription
medication let's say that's an you know
a lot a lot of people are consuming CBD
for an enzyme so if you are on a
medication like an SSRI aunt Ann's ie
or on antidepressant and you consume
your CBD together with your medication
it may actually inhibit the uptake the
efficacy but reduce the uptake of your
prescription medication so being aware
that it will really be helpful and
speaking to your health care
professional of how do i consume CD with
you know with my prescription medication
it's really key that you have that
conversation it's one thing to consume
an antidepressant or anti-anxiety
medication but you can be consuming
something that's more necessary for for
your life which is like a blood thinner
medication so like an orphan for
instance so that can also affect the
efficacy of your blood thinner
medication so just be aware of that and
it be aware of when you consume your
medication or your cannabinoid
meditation to make sure that it's tested
make sure that it's you know free of
pesticides or the metals etc the other
thing that I want to mention on CD as a
dive deeper into the other cannabinoids
is and this is having to do with most
cannabinoids anyway your metabolic
function is really really important in
the way you consume different
cannabinoids and on the CBD front a lot
of us make mm-hmm expensive urine in a
way so based on our fast ability to
metabolize when ultra fast metabolizer
maybe we you know we need more on
cannabinoids but if we're slow
metabolizer we need less so being able
to understand that
all people the dosing processes that's
the thing that when you mentioned out
CVD but it is an incredible cannabinoid
with many many many very very
therapeutic qualities so I want to talk
about some other cannabinoids as well so
THC that most people already know and it
is great for appetite and the reason why
it was for appetite it stimulates an
area of the brain in our amygdala that
is a pleasure principle and what how
much have better way to get pleasure
than Ivan like out fatty sugary and
salty foods and that's kind of what
happens so can you think about somebody
consuming THC at some point and they're
getting you know what people refer to as
the munchies think about I don't think
too many people are getting munchies for
kale per se so that's that's where the
area is stimulated and it has that kind
of effect and I already mentioned the
acid molecule so when you see in a next
to it it's not secretory circular active
in a way until the carboxyl baker-bots
relation madness which is the heating
process I mentioned CVD there over 80
total cannabinoids and you know what
there's even more I was in the lab
recently and we were looking at mass
spectrometer readings and we're in the
master chart reading list of the weights
of the different cannabinoids that we
can actually say okay based on this
information we can we know this a city
but there's something remain picked up
the we couldn't write down fine so we're
not sure what those calories are but
there are even more I'm sure going to be
identified in the near future so the CBD
there's a lot of studies are going on
with CBD me right now and autism as anti
compulsive as a regulator of glucose
there's also CVG which is sort of you
know the father of a lot of different
cannabinoids
it's really good for muscle tension and
then CC which is anti microbial and then
you have CBN and CBN is really
interesting because CBN is really
a conversion phenomena what I mean by
that is on people that say this to me
sometimes they said hey you know I found
a bag of cannabis somewhere in my car I
had it forever in here and when I
consumed that you know nanos couch what
well it could be that your cannabis was
laying in direct sunlight for a while
what happens sometimes THC deteriorates
and it converts so I use it bananas an
example when it's green and has a really
formulas have all its nutrients when it
becomes yellow it's a perfect time to
consume and that's new cannabis that's
cure properly that has a full expression
with cannabinoids in Turkey profile and
when it starts going Brown they start
losing some of those you know 13
vitamins and that's what happens in in
THC deterioration and I converse to cen
which can be assertive as well so
nevertheless we collaborate and talk
about turkeys butter beans the oils the
essential oils that are glandular
secretions of the cannabis plant they're
very very important because they work
synergistically with the cannabinoids to
produce a certain effect now we talked
about indicas and sativas which you know
in my opinion are really non-existent
anymore because there's the the
endogenous or indigenous a sativa indica
king of ours
they've been let out for the most part
so what you have is we have a turkey
profile that helps to make a
determination how closely relates to an
indica or sativa so the the team of
artists trains that originally belonged
to a harsher climates in Southeast Asia
they express them much more easily
pungent smell and that was prevalent
with but mercy is the dominant terpene
profile and the ones that grew more in a
tree
or climbing in the Caribbean in in some
regions of Africa like their poison Maui
Wowi they have a little bit of a more
full kind of set and that's associated
more with Lyman II and that is more
dominant on the on the Satya side
because that gives you a little bit of a
boost up and the other one gives you
more of a data to take my feeling but
they weren't together really really well
to create this third unit gonna affect
that cannabis provides suggesting me so
but use of the terpenes I kind of
mentioned a couple of them already but
terpenes are found in all living plants
so plants produce turkeys as their
essential oils so it's not just for it
just not not only juicing cannabis
it's another substances of piety
obviously you know pine needles little
rosemary and basil and it's fit for
alertness memory retention mercy
surprise in this town of mangoes the
small rates lemongrass time and it's
really good for muscle tension but also
is a sedative limonene which is found in
peppermint for instance and and citrus
fruits and that's really really good for
it's an antifungal antibacterial but
also gives you that lift insert Onan and
dopamine little is found of lavender and
it's exactly what it is is calming and
relaxing and Korean feeling which is an
amazing anti-inflammatory it's also
found like peppers and cloves so give it
back to genetics why you know I'm doing
this this talk I really want to make
this an example that how important and
how cannabis to meet the super personal
turn experience and one of my primary
goals is risk mitigation I believe that
what people have a positive experience
with cannabis they'll tell other people
and the more people you tell them the
more we can mitigate the possibly
negative experience the more people will
have the more people communicate that
experience and we can finally get rid of
stigma associated is amazing plan so I
want to use this as an example to tell a
story so grandma Mary so Mary I don't
know 50 years ago I happen to eat a
brownie at a party in college and she
had an awful experience it now takes a
brownie obviously um she was she was you
had an anxiety even a panic attack
sweats and she swore off that she puts
it the devil's lettuce for years and
years and years and she wouldn't touch
unfortunately Mary got diagnosed with
cancer and she living in an assisted
living facility and one day she was
watching the show with dr. Sanjay Gupta
who talked about cannabis and its
effects on cancer and you know obviously
she trusted such a good day who does he
and then she happened to go to a
dispensary and decided to try this again
and she happened to pick up the
chocolate bar and she told the bartender
there that you know she an expiry so he
told her to limit the Milgram said she
would consume so uh Mary decided to take
a smaller piece than you know the 20
milligrams that was on their broken have
consumed it and had an awful experience
Mary I was sick and she started
hallucinating even as she reports sweaty
and she began to tell everybody in
hearses living facility do not take this
substance it's bad for him
now if Mary would have known that she is
a ultra slow metabolizer and she would
have consumed her cannabis and bypassed
for digestive system they were consuming
or through a sublingual method that's on
your tongue or your buccal cavity that's
located in your cheeks should bypass
your digestive system would have missed
this the slow metabolizer
metabolism
in fact that that goes to you digestive
system
never would have had a great experience
which go now she does what she consumes
caddos because she knows that she has a
she's a slow metabolizer enzymes are
digesting metabolites and cannabis
effectively and there's a gene
associated that called cyp2c9 as an
example
now there's also Jack Jack is a veteran
who suffers from PTSD his physician told
him about cannabis and you know Jack
being proud didn't want to tell anybody
that he was having a really hard time
with cannabis and he was getting panic
attacks anxiety now there's a couple of
genes that can have an association with
that but one of them is calm tea and
they called the warrior warrior gene so
what happens in the ineffective a lot of
veterans in the in the athletes actually
office sometimes you have a genetic
expression on the on the warrior side so
when you have extra you have that you
start ona's be pumping your blood stream
you have which actually also helps to
release cortisol so when you are when
you any situation is Jack but swim boats
are flying at him he's pretty calm he's
doing his business he knows what he has
to do
however but he's home and the birds are
chirping it's a beautiful day he's
looking out the window that anxiety
starts so what happens is he's on the
warrior side of the contingent and he
has his fight-or-flight this shredder
that he knows how to control calmly in a
situation but this can be exacerbated by
THC and also centering Cova becomes
measuring limonene so when Jack found
out that he had this Jenny profile Jack
was able to find the right ratio of
cannabinoids and turkeys that work
really well to mitigate the expression
of that gene so jack
to have a really positive experience
consume cannabis which he actually needs
for his PTSD so one of my favorite
quotes I truly believe in this the art
of medicine consists of amusing the
patient while nature cures the disease
your body wants to heal as long as you
are able to give your body exactly what
a person needs your body really wants to
heal so how do you do that how do you
help your body know what are actually
needed so it can heal itself well first
of all it's really important to know
that cannabis is personal and your
genetics really really matter in your
consumption so 99.9% of our genes but
the same it's that point one percent the
makes of difference and it creates that
experience is personalized to you now as
I mentioned cannabis is person and there
is a way that you can identify what your
genetic makeup is and how it relates to
your experience with cannabis and we are
able to do have our what we're now
research team of scientists we've
developed this ability that looks at
your genetic expression and sees how
cannabis works when you specifically so
we looked at every single gene does the
right or indirect association with your
endocannabinoids system and once we
identify those we have to come up with a
way of how to communicate that what
people consider canvassed for
specifically what symptomatic conditions
and where our genes play a role without
talking about diagnosis or without
talking about specific disease states
because that is what physicians sir do
and that's you know regulated by the FDA
so we came up with eight different
symptomatic conditions anxiety pain the
patents cognitive function sleep
metabolism depression and psychosis
so what we do is we look at your genetic
expression new genes as they're
associated with each one of those
intimate conditions and we show you the
results of how we can reduce and lessen
the adverse effects that may Express on
these genes and what is a more optimal
ratio of Kaname interviews that work
best with your own expression with your
own bodies so we have a directed
consumer kit it's called the endo DNA
kit and it comes in a box like this yeah
it's some directly to your home the way
that once it's pretty simple I've come
to skin in the box with these things
inside of it and it is you know I'll
explain how to use it in a second I also
want to say that but when forty million
people have taken some sort of genetic
test whether it's a 23 mini
it's an ancestry.com to find out know
your your history
well if you have taken one of these
tests you don't really have to swab
which I'll get into how it works you can
just upload your on the Headley belongs
to you and then you can upload that will
translate that information into giving
you a cannot move a profile
now we're only as good as a version of
the array but you know one of those
companies uses so the earlier versions
are 23 we had a lot more coverage than
gladder versions because they were going
for their FDA approval but it'll give
you a really good indication of a
cannabinoid profile that it's more
optimal to you so how does it work well
it's pretty easy
number one the kid that I just done
mentioned it comes up with that buccal
swab so the swab is basically a big
q-tip so you take the cue to Swami and
send it mouth your cheek
put it back put it back in the box that
it came in register it because it
belongs to you and security is extremely
important to us so
data's fully fully anonymized and then
you mail it back in the box that came in
and will notify you when your results
are read it takes about four weeks to
give the labs sequencing done so we can
get your results and it's and what you
get when you get your results is the
following things number one we give you
suggest a wellness plan suggestive
wellness plan looks at all those
symptomatic conditions and shows you
your genetic profile as I said it's
associated with those symptomatic
conditions the second thing that it does
is we look briefly at drug the drug
interactions at very high level and as I
mentioned earlier in my presentation how
important it is to understand when the
cannabinoids interact with the
prescription medication that you may be
taking just being aware of that is
really important we also give you your
optimal cannabinoid and terpene profile
as a ratio that's more associated with
your genetic expression and finally a
product suggestion match so the way that
we do that is we look at CUA who's our
test results that we get from different
labs and we align that with products
that are available within your certain
market based on the galleries and based
on availability of those results and we
will suggest that there's products match
fairly well with us adjust the ratios
and here's where you can get those
products so an example be if you say
California then you know you can pretty
much have a dispensary a manufacturer or
delivery service would possibly get your
products almost anywhere and human
Canada it would be a licensed producer
if you're in Florida it may be one of
the vertically integrated
you know dispensaries are also cultivate
and if you're in New York for instance
you may have to go to your medical
clinic or the physician but actually
administers cannabis as medicine so
that's the way once based on the
galleries and your sip coming location
we also we also have filed
IP on different formula
that also align really well with your
genetic expression and there's
manufacturers throughout the country
actually in Canada that use those
formulations kind of a recipe and they
manufacture products the more aligned
with your genetic expression under their
own personal brands so I just want to
disclose that in full transparency so
this is I really really want to talk
about privacy and confidentiality it's
really important so when you get your
test results you log in to your secure
portal now the secure portal everything
is stored on on AWS Amazon secure server
now your personal information resides at
once sir your DNA isn't another server
everything is fully encrypted
we're HIPAA compliant and your
informations are anonymized so we don't
know until it's dynamically built we
don't know this early base DNA until
that report is built an advocate for you
so and the reason for that is we don't
care as much about Lemay's data we can't
we have a thousand samples a thousand
people that have this chanc marker that
specifically works well with this
profile and ratio of cannabinoids and
herpes and that's the feedback loop that
we're looking for
not necessarily my own personal
information that's not really our
interest it's to be able to create more
personalized client medicine use of
cannabis that are associated with your
own genetic expression individually so
once you once you log into your secure
server you'll have a summary of your
reports there's also survey that's
associated with I'm the reason for the
survey is we wanted to know what it is
that's most important to you so if
anxiety is really something of an issue
to you that information will be served
up as an aggregate of your different
genes that have to do with anxiety and
anxiety may be exacerbated by
that response the stress response that I
mentioned before of Ananda mite that and
can be triggered by THC and liming and
other things so just understand that and
being able to serve them from hmm
that's really important so to address
that with the survey information in
addition we also take it a step further
where we provide you information that
specific as an aggregate to your
suggestion wellness plan and how to dose
correctly as well based on your
metabolic function so as we dig deeper
and if you want to dig deeper it's up to
you because we give you a summary it's
really simple but if you want to D count
in science like me I want to do deep I
wouldn't understand what's creating fear
what's fear extinction what is my stress
response what are the traits that have
to do with anxiety so we give you sort
of a really simple way to do that and to
look at different gauges and the gauges
at work this way when you have it when
you're in the red you have an increased
risk or near the yellow you have a
moderate risk when you're in grieving
and you have a decreased risk like an
example inside you have to stress and
you can be able to click on each
individual section and get deeper into
the results of that experience so we'll
show you the exact genes that we
actually look for will show you personal
what's called the phenotype of your own
genetic expression now look at your
traits and after doing that we will give
you a suggestion on what is your
formulation as it pertains to that
symptomatic condition inside so if
you're looking to address anxiety and
this is your optimal formulation we'd
break you down into what the ratio will
be so we suggest for you know as an
example in eighteen to one to four to
one and the reason for that is it's
based on your personal experience for
THC so if you
novice you may want to start with a high
ratio of singing @hc but I'm titrate
your way down and we'll show you
reference I say studies for trials that
show you how THC may complicate or
exacerbate anxiety we also give you a
primary and secondary profile so little
works on reducing anxiety and we'll give
you these studies they're associated
with that as well
but I mentioned before the immune
response that creates inflammation and
beta kerryevelyn is really good as an
anti-inflammatory working in conjunction
with your cannabinoids so who benefits
from this test but before I even jump
into that I want to say one thing that
when when people some of the questions
that I've had is well sometimes you get
a contradiction but I said yeah
absolutely because there is no one thing
so people said that's fine just to be
one single things can't trust all my
means and I want to just preface
cannabis is not a cure-all it's not a
silver bullet it's an amazing adjunct if
you find what's right for you and it
works to us as a third pubic agent the
many different things however an example
would be whether you have a conflict
let's say that somebody is has some
issues sleeping but base their genetic
profile it says that they can consume a
higher level of THC with a turkey
profile that is going to help them you
know be more veining and relaxed buzzer
don't sleep however they also saw in
their genetic profile the THC can it is
a civilian side so what do they do
there's a the economy there's a conflict
well what you do is you're empowered you
have the information to make a decision
for the first time in your life on how
to consume properly so what you may want
to do is do today when you have some
environmental factors that contribute a
genetic expression anxiety maybe what
you want to do is get more equal titrate
up on your CBD maybe pursue something
more about one-to-one with the turkey
that's not gonna trigger that you mimic
its fashion so having little having
mercy having bakery and at night when
you're in the comfort of your own homee
may be when it consumes something that
has a little bit higher THC than may be
made tricky that genetic expression
that'll help you sleep better as long as
you keep the terpene profile aligned
with your genetic expression to mitigate
that anxiety come up as I mentioned
before little mercy etc so that's the
way you would use that and you have the
information to empower yourself so who
benefits most eyes I mean in my opinion
it's anybody who wants to consume
cannabis for any reason whatsoever so if
you're looking if you're new to cannabis
and you really want to try it you know
this is a baseline this is your
foundation you start with this and a
uniform the way I kind of look at us so
no people say you're the 23d of cannabis
etc I don't feel with you 23andme of
cannabis if we use that but look at us
more as your GPS and what I mean by that
is your GPS is your god it shows you but
this road over here is full traffic desk
construction this is a road you may want
to avoid this road over here is a much
better path but it doesn't guarantee
there won't be some potholes along the
way so what's next for a new kind of
health well what's next is different
things that we're looking at not only
your single pathways that I mentioned
but in addition there's other things
that can trigger your genetic and
expression so nutrition what you eat how
you think high dose so these are the
next different tests they were also
going to integrate and show you as I
mentioned before those say according to
your genetic profile and what kind of
metabolizer you are and it
creating additional products getting
more exposure
internationally so we were already in
the US and Canada we're already in
Australia New Zealand and we're moving
to other countries around the world
what's really exciting is we have a
partnership with a company called ward
medical management Australia and we're
gonna be doing six clinical trials so
people say well how do you know works
how do you know there's not enough data
it's not information well there's over
15,000 articles and cannabis alone I've
met but the clinical trials that we're
going to be doing under the TGA in
Australia that's gonna go a long way for
us to be able to say not only do we know
anecdotally but we can actually
reference specific trials but the first
one's gonna be a late stage dementia
patients they'll be swabbed genetically
they'll all be given a formulation of
cannabinoids and Inter beans I and we
will see if if their response is gonna
be different based on their genetic
profile and that's super super exciting
so just to kind of say what our goal is
is to take the guesswork out so
depending on where you live what your
state laws are you can go to a
dispensary have an intelligent
conversation or you can bypass in that
conversation and just say do you have
XYZ product available to you so that's
really what our goal is so what we are
on what we're focusing on is a way to be
able to provide this information also to
the physicians that are using this so
working with States working with
physicians that you actually have a
conversation with our patient there is a
physician portal since it's HIPAA
compliant that's really the goal to be
able to address not only the individual
which that information belongs to you
but having a conversation with your
overall treatment plan with your
healthcare provider and that's kind of
what our next step goal is to be able to
align this just with an individual
and also for your physician so I want to
thank everybody for your time I know
that it's very hard to take time out of
your day to learn and educate yourself
you know my feeling is that this is the
most amazing substance that we have just
the tip of the iceberg starting to look
at and see how it can really work for
the individual and just remember it is a
personal experience there's ways now
that you can actually target and know
specifically how how cannabis can affect
you but I'm kind of a skinny person so
thank you so much you're really
appreciate time Thank You Len for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye